so let's answer another question related
to cruciferous someone wanted to know if
it's okay to consume cruciferous because
they're concerned about the thyroid and
the endocrine system is it going to
create problems with the thyroid all
right so there it is true there is a
chemical called Theo sign 8 okay
in cruciferous vegetables not all of
them some of them and this chemical has
the capacity to compete for iodine so
since the thyroid needs iodine as its
mineral the last thing we want to do is
have this chemical computer iodine and
end up with a hypo thyroid condition
right but here's the thing it's not
gonna happen unless you are iodine
deficient in the first place but if
you're doing healthy keto if you're
taking trace minerals or seek help and
you even consume a good amount of
cruciferous you're not gonna have a
problem and one study 15 grams of
cruciferous per day were consumed that's
5 ounces of cooked brussel sprouts
ok for 4 weeks absolutely no adverse
effects whatsoever and one more point
about that when I recommend consuming 7
to 10 cups of vegetable per day I'm not
talking about 7 to 10 cups of
cruciferous vegetables per day that
might have been a confusion for some
people I couldn't consume that much
brussel sprout or broccoli or whatever
I'm talking about like leafy green
salads not even spinach but just leafy
green romaine lettuce or some other
lettuce mixture a couple cups of
cruciferous per day would be more in
line of what I would recommend and for a
lot of them you want to steam or saute
them or stir-fry them but the benefits
of cruciferous are huge anti tumor
anti-cancer anti-angiogenesis is
basically a situation where the tumor
has these blood vessels supplying its
nutrients and cruciferous has the
capacity of shutting off the growth of
these blood vessels to the trimmer
starving them of nutrients
there's nutrient benefits folate high
vitamin C high
michaei one potassium selenium calcium
tons of phytonutrients lots of
chlorophyll very very healthy for the
body but I think the biggest benefit is
its potential for creating a phase 1
phase 2 detoxification and that's a
situation where it will help boost the
breakdown of poisons and chemicals in
the body through certain enzymes in the
liver and so you're basically taking
these fat soluble poisons and turning
them into harmless water soluble
particles so the body can then rid them
thereby increasing liver function and
kidney function well guess what you need
good liver and kidney function to allow
the conversion from t3 to t4 so without
a healthy liver or a healthy kidney
you're not going to be able to convert
these thyroid hormones and of course the
fiber and the cruciferous could feed the
microbes and provide food to increase
the bile or recycling and then the bile
is also necessary for this immersions
well so you can actually improve the
thyroid by consuming some cruciferous
and I'm not talking about massive
amounts just some in the diet and
realize when you cook it or ferment it
you decrease some of these chemicals as
well and not to mention cruciferous
having the anti-estrogen ik effect and
high levels of estrogen inhibit thyroid
function so you're really helping the
thyroid with cruciferous as long as you
have enough iodine so this is why I
recommend a seek help especially if
someone is susceptible to having a
thyroid problem seek help is very
important and if you're consuming more
cruciferous just add more seek help
alright thanks for watching
if you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos